With his dome helmet, purple cloak, and fishnet-covered
green bodysuit, Mysterio's an instantly recognizable
supervillain.
But just because you can recognize him on
sight doesn't mean you know everything about
the arachnid-hating trickster who's been one
of Marvel's most tenacious villains.
Of everyone who's ever worn Mysterio's fishbowl
helmet, Quentin Beck — created by Steve
Ditko and Stan Lee — is by far the most
well-known.
“Here to save the world from the evils of
technology corrupting the human spirit.”
“...Are we being punked?”
Originally a stuntman and makeup artist who
turned to crime after getting frustrated with
the movie industry, Beck first appeared in
Amazing Spider-Man #13.
His first step in taking down Spider-Man was
to impersonate the masked webhead by using
his technological prowess to mimic Spidey's
powers and frame him for various crimes.
With Spider-Man's popularity at an all-time
low, Mysterio could swoop in as a hero when
he took down Spider-Man along with keeping
the money he'd stolen earlier.
As you'd expect, Spider-Man took down Mysterio
and cleared his name, but Mysterio would continue
to pop up over the years, including a role
as one of the original members of the Sinister
Six.
However, one of his most interesting roles
came in 1980, when Beck was revealed as having
actually appeared way back in the second issue
of Amazing Spider-Man, disguised as one of
a crew of aliens in a truly bizarre early
story.
This helped to establish what is arguably
Mysterio's greatest strength as a character:
he can make any story work with his mastery
of illusions… no matter how weird it might
get.
Mysterio's focus is usually less about killing
Spider-Man than trying to drive him insane,
a quirk that shows up very early in the character's
identity.
In 1965's Amazing Spider-Man #24, Mysterio's
dedication to the long con is truly demonstrated
when Dr. Ludwig Rinehart arrives at the Daily
Bugle, making a compelling case that Spider-Man
is a hair's breadth away from complete insanity.
Spidey shrugs it off at first, but when he
begins to see his arch-villains crawling out
of the walls to attack him before disappearing
in smoke, he's a bit more convinced.
He pays Dr. Rinehart a visit to see if he
can get some help, but the hallucinations
get so bad that Spider-Man gets one step away
from revealing his secret identity.
Fortunately, Daily Bugle boss J. Jonah Jameson
bursts in to accuse the not-so-good doctor
of being a fraud.
With his mind clear, Spidey quickly defeats
Dr. Rinehart and discovers, as you might expect,
that it's actually Quentin Beck in disguise.
While Beck's plan wasn't successful, it established
his modus operandi early on — Mysterio could
never beat Spider-Man in a fair fight, so
he uses deception to drive the wall-crawler
to defeat himself.
Mysterio, master of existentialism
Another notable attempt at getting Spidey
to crack came in 1992's Web of Spider-Man
#90.
In the issue, Spider-Man finds himself taking
on the world-devouring Galactus, and wakes
up afterwards to discover that he's a card-carrying,
A-list celebrity who's been enjoying the good
life ever since his brief stint in the wrestling
ring against Crusher Hogan — an event that
happened way back in his very first appearance.
Something's amiss on the set of his newest
feature film, when some of his toughest villains
attack.
After dispatching Hobgoblin and Venom, Spidey
figures out what's really going on.
Mysterio hired Max Shiffman to help him construct
an entire alternate life for Spider-Man to
get trapped in.
While the plot is classic Mysterio, the issue
is notable for an additional wrinkle that
it provides to Mysterio's character.
While fighting Spider-Man, Mysterio, disguised
as Venom, reveals that when his helmet was
cracked during their first fight, it exposed
Quentin to the hallucinogenic mists that lets
him control illusions.
With his exposure to the mists, his own grasp
on reality was shattered, leaving him unable
to tell illusion from reality.
It's an interesting idea, but it’s only
occasionally been revisited since.
The Marvel Universe has always been connected.
The very first issue of Amazing Spider-Man
has him dropping by to hassle the Fantastic
Four, and Spidey and Daredevil in particular
have an especially long bad guy exchange program.
The Kingpin, Daredevil's greatest and most
well-known arch-enemy, was originally a Spider-Man
villain, and The Owl, Electro, and, of course,
Mysterio have all jumped back and forth between
the heroes.
In "Guardian Devil," a 1998 arc of Daredevil
written by filmmaker Kevin Smith and drawn
by future Marvel Editor-in-Chief Joe Quesada,
Daredevil wrestles with the responsibility
of taking care of a child that seems to be
either the Messiah or the Anti-Christ.
However, after a quick consultation with Dr.
Strange and Mephisto — the actual, literal
Devil in the Marvel Universe — he realizes
that he's been drugged and that the baby is
just a baby.
Mysterio, newly diagnosed with lung cancer
and an inoperable brain tumor from his years
of getting high off of his own hallucinogenic
supply, had enacted a grand revenge scheme
against his second-most hated foe.
Once the trick was revealed, Mysterio was
hopeful that Daredevil would kill him.
Once that failed, Mysterio took care of the
matter himself, in a death that spelled the
end for Quentin Beck's run as Mysterio…
for a while.
“I always did like a good cliffhanger.”
While there are other people who have worn
the Mysterio mantle in the main Marvel Universe,
also known as Earth-616, there's another version
worth mentioning: the Mysterio of the Ultimate
Universe.
While other characters would get a complete
top-to-bottom reimagining for Marvel’s rebooted
Ultimate comics, the Ultimate version of Mysterio
wasn't all that different from the 616 version.
He first showed up in Ultimate Spider-Man
Annual #3, and his biggest difference from
his 616 counterpart was that he had a worse
costume.
While some would find fault with a fishnet-covered
green bodysuit and fishbowl helmet, you can't
argue that it isn't immediately recognizable.
The Ultimate version of Mysterio had none
of his predecessor's flair, using only a boring
ghost-like effect over his face as a disguise.
As it turns out, though, there was a reason
that the Ultimate Mysterio wasn't all that
different from the 616 version.
In a truly weird plot twist, it was eventually
revealed that they weren't actually two characters
at all.
Instead, the Ultimate Mysterio was a ridiculously
high-tech android piloted across universes
by the 616 Mysterio in order to… accomplish
the same kinds of crimes that he got up to
in his home universe.
No, really.
It happened in Spider-Men, a series where
the core universe’s Peter Parker traveled
across dimensions to mentor the Ultimate Universe’s
new Spider-Man, Miles Morales.
If that's all sounding just a bit familiar,
it's because the plot was loosely adapted
for 2018's Into the Spider-Verse motion picture,
along with a couple of other cross-dimensional
Spider-Man stories.
Spider-Men ended with Mysterio in custody
in the Ultimate Universe, leaving the role
of Mysterio to be filled by other, lesser
criminal geniuses.
Quentin Beck is the original, but he’s not
the only Mysterio.
In Amazing Spider-Man #141, Daniel Berkhart
appears as a stuntman who took over for Beck,
who had faked his own death at the time.
While it's hard for any villainous replacement
to surpass the original, Berkhart was less
notable than most, and never really had a
unique spin on the Mysterio identity.
His most well-known stories involved him pretending
to be a resurrected Quentin Beck in order
to torment Spider-Man.
When your best-known plot involves pretending
to be a more beloved character and generally
succeeding, you're not really going to last
long in a comic book universe.
Even when he got title billing in his own
miniseries, Spider-Man: The Mysterio Manifesto,
he spent most of the story dressed as an entirely
different second-string supervillain: Jack
O'Lantern.
Spooky!
Created by Rachel and Terry Dodson and Kevin
Smith in Spider-Man/Black Cat: The Evil That
Men Do, Francis Klum is arguably the worst
Mysterio.
“Ah, Spider-Man my nemesis.
You won’t catch me this time!”
Unlike others, Klum actually has super-powers:
he's a mutant with the ability to teleport,
along with some assorted telepathy and telekinesis.
In a complicated series of events, Klum ended
up accidentally getting knocked off a bridge
by Spider-Man, which led to Klum losing part
of his leg, and naturally, this led him to
embark on a crusade of vengeance against Spider-Man
dressed as one of his old enemies.
His crusade of vengeance didn't last long,
though — he was interrupted by both Beck
and Berkhart who were not happy about gimmick
infringement.
Even worse for Klum, he was eventually stabbed
in the chest by thousands of spiders wearing
the form of a school nurse that’s comics,
baby!
While Berkhart and Klum popped up to cover
for Beck while he was dead, who fought Spider-Man
while Beck was stuck in the Ultimate Universe
after the events of Spider-Men?
A brand new character called Mysterion.
Created by David Lopez and Christopher Yost
in Avenging Spider-Man #22 - which was the 23rd issue because... you know what? just forget it.
Comics... am I right? Anyway... Mysterion was…
well, basically the same as previous Mysterios,
except not quite as competent.
In the issue, he picks up the costume and
gear from Hobgoblin before running afoul of
both the Punisher, who kills supervillains,
and the Superior Spider-Man, a Spider-Man
with the soul of Doctor Octopus who also kills
supervillains.
Somewhat surprisingly, he actually managed
to survive the encounter and popped up a couple
more times in the Marvel Universe — most
notably when he took on the unbeatable Squirrel
Girl and all of the Avengers with robot dinosaurs.
Unfortunately, without an actual name or defining
features, we're unlikely to see much more
of Mysterion going forward.
Considering how closely his power set aligns
with movie magic, you would have expected
Mysterio to make an appearance in a cinematic
Spider-Man adaptation long before 2019's Spider-Man:
Far From Home.
As it turns out, he quite nearly did.
Jeffrey Henderson, a storyboard artist who
worked with Sam Raimi on the original cinematic
Spider-Man trilogy, revealed that a planned
Spider-Man 4 would have included Mysterio,
along with a handful of other Spider-Foes.
Apparently the idea was to run through lower-tier
villains like the Shocker, the Prowler, Rhino,
Stilt-Man, and, of course, Mysterio, since
they figured they would never be chosen as
the main antagonists of other films.
As for who would portray the master of illusions
in the quick cameo, Henderson suggested that
Bruce Campbell, a longtime Sam Raimi collaborator
who had made brief cameos in all of the previous
Spider-Man movies, could step beneath the
bowl to play Quentin Beck.
It never happened, but it’s not hard not
to be intrigued by what the scenery-chewing
Campbell could've done with one of Mysterio's
many monologues.
“Ah, Romance!
I am French!”
“...uh.”
It took him a long time to get his big-screen
due, but Mysterio finally made the jump to
theaters courtesy of Jake Gyllenhaal's portrayal
in 2019's Spider-Man: Far from Home.
In some ways, his long journey to the big
screen is a good thing.
With the huge advances in CGI and special
effects technology made in the last couple
of decades, there's arguably no better time
for a supervillain to harness the lifelike
illusions and movie magic trickery of Mysterio.
Plus, given Gyllenhaal's deeply upsetting
portrayal of an amoral psychopath in 2014's
Nightcrawler, it's almost guaranteed that
the villain will be just as creepy and unsettling
as his best stories make him out to be.
Here's hoping this latest incarnation of this
enduring Marvel character ends up sticking
around for more than a single outing — and
signals a future in which the MCU's villains
only get weirder and wilder.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.